yep I am busting out the sweater it was
snowing on the way to the movie tonight
[Music]
the counselor is directed by Ridley
Scott and stars Michael Fassbender
Penelope Cruz Cameron Diaz Brad Pitt
humongous cast in this movie filled with
very tons of people and to describe this
movie is sort of like weaving through a
maze it's like you can go one direction
and that sort of takes you somewhere but
then it immediately will take a left
turn and you're not exactly sure where
you are and then you're lost and that's
kind of the best way that I can describe
the counsellor because essentially if
you read like the IMDB synopsis it says
that a lawyer gets involved in drug
trafficking and then he finds himself in
over his head that is the easiest way to
sum up this movie and really the only
way that I can sum up this movie even
though I just watched it the only way
that I can truly tell you what this
movie is about is because I read the
IMDB synopsis now I was looking forward
to this movie based on the cast and the
director alone these are hugely talented
individuals and people that have made
great entertainments in the past and so
for that reason I was excited to see
this movie I was the only person tonight
at midnight there was no screening for
it in my area that's why I did go to the
theater tonight at midnight to see it I
had the entire theater myself it was
pretty cool and that would have been
pretty freakin awesome
if this movie wasn't horrible the
counselor is the biggest most colossal
miscalculation I have seen all year and
what I mean by that is there are so many
talented people in this movie so many
people who you see and you begin to
expect much more from it looks like a
good movie it looks like a well made
movie the problem with this movie is the
screenplay I have no idea what this
movies about I will not lie to you this
is the most confusing movie I've seen
all year none of it makes sense
it doesn't feel like it flows it doesn't
have a natural progression of events
characters emote things that you feel
okay this is a big moment but you don't
know why it's a big moment because you
don't understand who this character is
or what they're doing or what they're
trying to do because this movie doesn't
explain anything to you and I know the
kind of audience member that needs to be
spoon-fed information to be able to
enjoy my movies I like being able to
figure out a movie I like a mystery
that's like a labyrinth where you have
to try to weave your way through it and
try
figure out different points but this is
a movie that doesn't have any of those
elements in it because there's no
mystery there's no suspense the only
mystery in this movie is how in the hell
it got made with so many famous people
in it because certain elements of this
movie you feel like okay they're going
for something really cool and different
here but you don't understand why
because it's so poorly written
you cannot grasp this movie there's
nothing about it that makes it
interesting
there's nothing intriguing about it it's
just a giant overflow of scenes where
you witness some horrible things you
witness people doing absolutely idiotic
things and you don't really know what it
all means you don't care about any of
the characters because you don't get to
know any of the characters they're just
like vessels for words to come out of
the best way I can describe it it's like
all the actors who are walking through
the shots are just actors it's like oh
there's Brad Pitt I like him he's a good
actor
I guess that's Brad Pitt in a cowboy hat
you don't know anything about him you
don't learn anything about him there's
nothing about him that's intriguing same
with Michael Fassbender who is a
fantastic actor who gives a good
performance in this movie but you just
you don't care at all about him he's
just the counsellor and I guess that
means he's a lawyer and I guess he's
involved in some sort of drug deal
that's it that's the counselor look I
see hundreds of movies each year and I
could not grasp this movie I know that
your average audience member who just
wants to go see a movie because I like
Brad Pitt or because I like Michael
Fassbender is gonna walk into this movie
and be like what and Cameron Diaz in
this movie look I don't have a problem
with her at all she's very attractive
woman she's given good performances in
the past but here she just misses it
like she everyone in this movie was just
not right like it just didn't feel as if
it was on the right path that it should
be on it was such a random and strange
movie filled with odd scenes like people
humping a windshield of a car like what
I was the only person in the theatre as
I said earlier I was so bored by this
movie that I kind of like stretched my
legs out over the seat next to me and
just kind of laid like this and watched
it and tried to stay awake I mean it
this movie really was a humongous
miscalculation on everyone
part it's actually one of the worst
films I've seen all year because it
doesn't make any sense it doesn't feel
as if anything happens in this movie
it's just a random series of events and
there are famous actors wandering in and
out of the frame the one piece of
marketing that actually intrigued me on
this movie was a clip that was shown
before a YouTube video that I saw and it
was Michael Fassbender and another
character who he actually is in this
movie talking about stockings or
something lead lady's underwear over a
counter and apparently it was for the
councillor yeah that seems definitely
not in the movie those characters never
meet it was a shameless piece of
marketing to make you intrigued about a
movie that the studio's know no one's
gonna be intrigued by and that's pretty
offensive I'm sorry
that's stupid I'm gonna give the
councillor a D I think that it has some
good performances in it Michael
Fassbender is good Brad Pitt's good but
none of it ever comes to a point where
you're like yeah that was worth sitting
in this seat for two hours and by the
way as a reminder this weekend my scary
movie special part 1 & 2 is going to be
up part 1 will be up later today Friday
and part 2 will be up on Sunday we have
made 5 skits / part in relation to the
horror films are going to be talking
about we've worked on this for over a
month and I really hope you guys watch
it and enjoy it
we're having various cameos from other
youtubers and it's just gonna be a lot
of fun to talk about some fun scary
movies also on October 31st I'm gonna be
releasing a video where I talk about my
least favorite horror remakes and
sequels there are so many I'm having the
hardest time of my life condensing that
video I hope you guys enjoy the next few
days filled with scary horror
awesomeness and as always if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]